Joe Biden's wife, Jill Biden, potentially
the future first lady of the United States,
depending on what happens in November, is
pretty clever.
And she's also quite astute when it comes
to dealing with media.
Now, certainly she's had media training.
I'm guessing it has been ramped up, given
that Joe Biden is the nominee up, but she
seems to have a bit of a natural ability for
this.
I'm going to play a clip for you today of
Jill Biden completely shutting down CNN's
Jake Tapper, who tries to bring up the issue
of Joe Biden's gaffe.
And Jill, Biden does something that is really
it's a clinic on how to be interviewed.
She says gaffes.
Trump is president.
What are you talking about?
Joe Biden's gaffe.
So I'm going to play the clip for you.
Then we'll discuss it.
I'm resisting my instinct to first tell you
all of the interesting things about this clip.
I'm not going to do that.
Let's watch it first and then we will talk
about it.
Your husband has been known to make the occasional
gaffe.
You can't even go there.
You can after Donald Trump.
You know, I wanted to say the word.
I can't say the word gaffe now, but, you know,
done.
It's gone.
The gaffe issue is over.
So over.
So Jake Tapper doesn't even know how to respond.
And what Jill Biden did here is super interesting,
both from the perspective of the interviewer
and the perspective of the interviewee.
Now, I've been on both sides of this.
I've been the interviewer asking questions
of a guest that the guests may not want to
answer.
I've also been a guest being asked questions
that either, you know, it's not typically
that I don't want to answer them, but that
I either find boring or lame or distracting
or improperly framed questions.
So I've been on both sides of this.
Jill Biden has handled this perfectly in that
she resisted opening up the can of worms.
She reframed as we talk about it in a moment,
you'll see what I mean.
And she did it in a charming and friendly
way without attacking the interviewer and
without making it awkward, but simultaneously
reminding the audience of how absurd it is
to talk about Joe Biden's gaffes when the
president is Donald Trump.
There are two other ways that she could have
done this.
Based on the typical media training and preparation.
So one thing that Jill Biden could have done,
and she didn't do it.
One thing she could have done is to do a typical
standard reframe and pivot.
Okay, so that would be something like acknowledging
Biden's gaffes, but pivoting to issues which
would start with some kind of mild acknowledgment.
It might be, you know, what about what about
the gaffes?
You know, my husband, he says what's on his
mind, he's passionate.
And sometimes things come out in a way that
he would redo if given the chance.
But what this election is really about is
the future of this country and health care
and coronavirus.
So I'm sure if you've watched any interviews
in your life, you've heard people respond
that way when interviewed.
And the downside of it is it does feel like
not answering the question because it's not
really answering the question.
So she didn't do that the other way.
Joe Biden could have responded, would have
been to sort of more forcefully and noticeably
refused to answer.
And that often looks very bad.
Right.
So I'm not here to talk about that.
Or this is an election about issues, not about
gaffes or no comment.
Right.
I mean, that's really, really bad.
That's not good.
And she didn't do that.
But what Jill Biden does and we're going to
watch it a second time now, armed with the
knowledge of how to interpret this, what Jill
Biden does is to essentially make it a big
joke while being friendly and reminding people
that Biden's gaffes are nothing compared to
Trump's years of insults and attacks, attacks
and mocking of disabled reporter using racist
and xenophobic terms, suggesting people inject
bleach and on and on and on and the way, you
know that this was effective.
Is that Jeff?
Jake Tapper.
He's just out of ideas.
He retreats to just repeating what she says.
Jake Tapper says, oh, the issue is over.
Let's look at it.
One more time, your husband has been known
to make the occasional gaffe, you can't even
go there.
You can after Donald Trump, you get what I
want and say the word.
I can't even say the word gaffe now.
But, you know, done.
It's gone.
The gaffe issue is over.
We are so over.
So this might not seem that notable if you
don't look at it more deeply, but that is
actually a very skilled and tactful way to
handle this question and this issue.
And by the way, it's not just optics.
Jill Biden is right.
Sure.
Joe Biden has been gaffe prone over the years.
Donald Trump gaffes every week of this presidency
as much as Joe Biden has in the last decade.
And she was able to make that point without
insulting Jake Tapper, without attacking the
question or the network.
It's also, quite frankly, a bit of a lazy
question.
Let let's now look at it from the interviewer's
point of view.
If Jake Tapper wants to prevent Jill Biden
from being able to do this, he has to come
up with something more specific.
Your husband once said X and that was deeply
offensive to Y.
Why do you think he hasn't apologized?
Is he unwilling to admit that that was a mistake?
You have to frame the question more powerfully,
because if Jake Tapper does that, Jill Biden
can't get out of it as easily and as smoothly
as she did.
So this is partially that Jill Biden handled
the question really well and wasn't going
to put up with this absurd idea that the Biden
gaffes are the problem when you look at the
last four years of Trump.
But also, Jake Tapper brought it up in sort
of a lazy way and it allowed her to do this.
But her identifying it quickly and diffusing
it in a friendly and cordial way was what
was astute, really, a clinic on how to handle
interviews.
Let me know what you think.
Let me know what you're expecting for tonight's
debate, which we will be live for starting
at eight thirty p.m. Eastern Time on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
I look forward to hearing from you.